[Music]
in holy sheep new boy BAM aided by
cherry blossom cutter cool scientists
have created an artificial womb that
could help save prematurely born babies
I saw this dude wifey all these news
articles yeah so this I saw there's a
lamb and they put it like it looks like
a huge dip lock bag in it like
represented like are recreated a womb
scenario and like had all the fluids in
there and stuff and they grow like lamb
I want to see knit one I think you this
is really oversimplifying when a woman
goes through yeah bro the pox but only
forgot to write sure like so it was in
an actual heat before and then it was
premature baby was too early yeah I was
like twenty three weeks old or something
like that they need to put it back in
other just a little bit it's a little
longer it was too mushy inside what's
better than the baby being in that I'm
gonna show you guys this video this is a
sheep Nikita it's being boarded
so it was already boarded isn't wrong I
think about barbecue event so that's the
artificial womb they call it a bio bag
so I'm gonna play this video they're
gonna give you some facts that's
incredible it's like a vacuum cleaner
with a zip called visit Blood Pack yeah
you would think it would need to be in
the dark because like you don't actually
do keep it in the dark okay to turn on
the light please video remember et tu
this runs a YouTube
PTSD format I love ET this scene always
freaking out though yeah weird that's
what it looks like inside you do yes it
looks like is that all liquid it's just
suspended in liquid yeah it's under [ __ ]
where do they find premature lambs or do
they have to construct that [ __ ] I hope
they didn't [ __ ] up the mama lamb just
like premature baby but I'm not sure how
they appeal it probably is that's [ __ ]
up man you see mama lens like we're
gonna reject it it's like you're born to
[ __ ] the bag I don't even know you smell
like a bag all the other sheep are going
to make fun of it and go Lea no back
baby back I could do that just give me a
dip lock bag and I'll [ __ ] plug in
Gatorade the coconut water and the baby
could survive all the shows too easy
dude awesome
that's amazing Wow I don't know why we
didn't think of this sooner my
ultrasound I keep [ __ ] hub called
[ __ ] I'm creating missile I would be
like oh that was Jessica that's Mary if
you did an ultrasound and it was a rave
like that now no you do see that yeah
picturing that with the blood vessels
slow right that's a baby Coachella tell
us the details
so the denial bag is a clear plastic bag
in order to protect this infant
prematurely born land and so all that
fluid that was in there it's electrolyte
solution with and it also has a good
continuous flow exchange so it's
continuously exchanging that solution
like circulating exactly that's like an
Aquarian for layman's you know for
people who'd understand which is the
same thing that happens in the womb of
woman it's an aquarium at night yeah so
there's a scuba diver a treasure chest
yep a little bubbles yeah okay I have to
clean it out good times visual synthetic
allergy grandpa costumers massage canal
- it's weird you don't want to see it
inside a woman's belly
don't let me show you the ultrasound
pictures you see it also has that
artificial umbilical artery in order to
circulate the blood and to exchange of
carbon dioxide and oxygen and so in a
way I didn't know they moved that much
like the lamb was like like it was like
this Impala guys that I got wonder was
thinking about that's what I think about
what my cat blinking and doing that
because it looks like it's talking to
itself I think because it's developing
like for the longest it could move right
because it just looks like a weird
embryo looking thing and then the more
develops and it gets bigger than it
starts like having like these reflexes
and it can't control it like oh [ __ ]
we'll be walking blood let's go me
[ __ ] doing it yeah literally like the
actual hands I popped through like I'm
not ready
I have a video Zizek doing there my
belly was freaking trigger
do they ever squeeze your belly button
he's a preemie lamb or yeah man
they were there for four weeks and
during that time their lungs and brain
grew they developed more I need a bag
like that formula don't like athlete
sleeping those guys they do what is that
the gym deprivation training oxygen same
kind of jam
I keep screaming younger some [ __ ] is
more red blood cell yeah you decrease it
on the amount of oxygen and then you
increase your input I feel like if we go
into those chambers we will heal faster
you do like you have a lot of time after
working out all alone on your laptop you
pull up a private window and look up
[ __ ] about like how to preserve your
life and then someone comes in the room
you like okay makes a gun look at the
cork look at far like a normal person
there's manases devices bio bag it's
kept in a warm place in the darkroom
with the sounds of the moms heartbeat I
don't feel like they're actually in the
womb and so there during they also
inhale this liquid for the lungs to be
able to develop and what they're saying
is that in the u.s. 10 percent of babies
are born prematurely which means a lot
actually yeah they were born before 37
weeks which normally they're born at 40
weeks brings all the beta male [ __ ] I
mean all the time yeah you know what you
can't just put that baby in an incubator
and think presto that she looks no that
looks bad I saw this video on YouTube I
mean on Facebook like two nights ago
from a baby that was prematurely born
like 24 weeks it was like really tiny
but I don't know how they kept him alive
to put in the incubator and put like
tubes in his mouth and [ __ ] eat them
like baby food but he doesn't have to
throw it and everything that dish so
this is one step closer to being natural
they haven't tested on human yet and
what they should do is go to the woman's
jail and hire those ladies to just hold
the babies for comfort they need the
body warmth you know that's the next
step put the baby in the bag coconut
water but don't let them tell them
stories Caitlyn yeah you just hold that
but you don't tell many stories because
you're on the Tom bass story what I
thought you're going to say is it should
go to the women's jail and then have
them prematurely like have a kid you're
crazy Jill I'm just so upset you were
going to say that you're crazy because
you thought that he was going to because
I'm trying to tap into the crazy part of
my brain I would have just said lactate
them and give them actual mother's milk
but then I thought about all the drugs
and heroin in those titty milk is there
anything preemies don't have
because the moms busy working she's
working on a corporate gig she's got
time to pick a break to [ __ ] fold the
baby all day and you need multiple women
you can't just have one it made sense
why I went to crazy town because that's
the only objective thing I can think of
why he would bring up prison that women
can work right
this generation women can work but
prison women they can and they're born
again they wait but just kill the baby
cuz like where they're going to go jail
you there is already imprisoned sorry
let me say the senior citizen home
anyway back to statistics so 6% of the
10% of babies born prematurely they're
considered extremely premature and
that's about 30,000 babies so they're
saying that that's when the baby's born
before 28 weeks and these artificial
wombs potentially eventually they could
be really beneficial for these babies
because when humans are born prematurely
it's the lung heart like the last things
to develop the can't breathe yeah and so
you need to live underwater
exactly they need they need that Amiata
food to be able to still continue to
develop the lung and their family's
extremely preemie babies a lot of them
tend to die because if they can't
survive in the outside world and I'm at
fault so they're not frogs yet I like
within those 20-something weeks or died
like later in life they release about
the hospital and they're like no I just
like they couldn't survive like being
born so prematurely I don't know like
what the time frame is oh my gosh no
babies in an event as a baby okay so why
are they bagging the babies now because
they still don't have that technology
and bag them up so I think I wrap it up
thanks difference to my a man a baby
dude may be that much different yes what
they're developing as of right now this
is very for this different console's
taking clones lambs right now they can't
clone people yeah but it's I think it's
an ethical but if that's your baby right
now you're like yo put it in the
clinical trial but not
season I wouldn't say yeah just [ __ ]
let the baby die with the other babies
you can have it in [ __ ] yours body
for [ __ ] six months or yeah what a
minute I make up what to McDonalds ones
oh that's dedication never made a mr.
Brian any honor your low maintenance and
worry I'm like what are you doing
he was relayed that's what I said yeah I
was like keep sucking up like she's got
to boss him around although you know in
it you don't need my help look at the
one time you get to take advantage of
that I know what the [ __ ] like doing
I don't know he's like she's so
independent like he look at you man the
whole house earlier and he's like I just
had a beer all right play this thing
better oh yeah girl has the advantage
and then ste was like I went to
Starbucks today for your salad yeah
what's left you go to Starbucks in the
valley I got all the Starbucks masalas
does all these every year 30,000 babies
died because they didn't hurry they've
been trying for decades that's 90
thousand babies scientists hurry though
huh you make a baby in your belly I do
it in a heartbeat you know it's not that
hard I cook a lot of people do half of
the world doesn't Geo hope you guys
enjoyed that episode if you guys have
any juicy little gusts of details and
you guys want to submit it well guess
what you can cruise on over to the
description box below click on the link
submit the story and hopefully we will
pick it and talk about it for more
videos click right over here
[Music]